oh yeah real-life English Learner I'm
Ethan your fluency coach in case you
didn't already know me and we have
another fantastic lesson this week from
friends a lot of your favorite TV series
much like mine
and in this scene today we are going to
see that Joey gives Chandler kind of a
strange present but in this lesson you
will also be learning a lot of
expressions vocabulary related to
friendship in English and I have a much
better present for you than what
Chandler gets it's a PDF power lesson
just like this one check it out and you
can download that right now by clicking
right up here at the top and you're
going to learn with that so much
vocabulary expressions grammar so much
more it will really help you master
everything that you learned today so go
download that right now and before we
get into today's lesson I have a quick
question for you do you like having fun
learning English I know you do that's
why you're here right then be sure to
support us by subscribing and liking
this video and you will get our newest
lessons every single week so that we can
help you make English learning fun
alright let's get into it
hey I got something for you well it's
this 812 bucks well I don't know what
big Leon told you but it's an even
thousand if you want me for the whole
night what is this for
well I'll make a money now and this is
paying you back for headshots electric
bills and so many slices of pizza I
can't even count I Love You Man
well thanks man now I can get my pony
this is a little extra something for uh
you know always being there for me wow I
don't know what to say wow I don't know
what to say I don't know it's a bracelet
is it it's great - check it out - my
best bud thanks best bud put it on oh no
no no I think something this nice should
be saved for a special occasion
oh no no that's the beauty part it goes
with everything you're good to go
oh man you are so wearing that bracelet
hi so I am you have any idea what this
will do for your sex life well it'll
probably slow it down at first but once
I get used to the extra weight I'll be
back on track you know Nan's got a point
it's a little flashy no no no it's not
flashy not for a good fella sure that
must have cost you quite a few doubloons
okay you gotta give me a second I want
to get this just right dude eleven
o'clock totally hot babe checking you
out that's really good think I'm ready
for my penis
I know what you're thinking Dave Thomas
founder of Wendy's I'm Gayle chilly I
really have to be somewhere but it was
nice meeting you
buzzes excellent you know he could have
got me a VCR he could have got me a set
of golf clubs but no he has to get me
the woman repeller the eyesore from the
Liberace House of crap oh yeah easy for
you to say you don't the walk around
sporting some reject from the mr. t
collection I pity the fool who puts on
my food hey man we were just doing some
impressions over here
do your myself myself that's actually
good if you hated the bracelet so much
channeling you should have just said so
well isn't the fact that I wore the
bracelet even though I hated it say
something about our friendship and how
much it means to me well what about the
fact that you insulted the bracelet and
you made fun of me okay well that's the
part where I'm a wink
some people wouldn't focus on that come
on man
I said I was sorry like a hundred times
I promise I will never take it off my
wrist
if you want to stay in there and be mad
you know you just you stay in there
I can't believe did you stop already get
out of the bitter barn and play in the
hay oh you're right I should play in the
hay forget about the fact I just dropped
$400 to replace a bracelet that I hated
to begin with bring on the hay I've got
something that's gonna make you happy
guess a Gunther phone oh no you have to
what am I gonna do huh hey hey how come
you have to well this one's for you no I
can't no no listen I I know how much
this means to you and I also know that
this is about more than just jewelry
it's about you and me and the fact that
we're best buds
oh is this friendship I think so
somebody's that's what they'll call us
how to talk about friendship in English
we have many terms of endearment that is
caring ways to refer to a friend or
loved one that one can use to address a
male friend in general a woman would not
like being addressed with these terms
but they may use it with guy friends in
this scene we see many used so listen
for them in the rest of the scene and
start using them in your own English to
sound more confident and native like
here are some examples man dude mostly
in the u.s. mate mostly outside of the
United States in countries like the UK
Australia and South Africa buddy or bud
bro brother pal
homey homes or Home Slice there are of
course more but these are probably the
ones that you will see used most
commonly in everyday English also feel
free to choose a couple of these and use
them in an example in the comments below
we will correct many of your answers 812
bucks bucks common informal word for
dollars example can you lend me five
bucks for the train ticket I don't know
what big Leon told you but it's an even
thousand if you want me for the whole
night it's an even thousand if you want
me for the whole night Chandler is
making a joke as if he were a prostitute
and that big Leon a name he invented in
the moment was his pimp a pimp is a
prostitutes manager and a male
prostitute is also known as a gigolo
what is this for
what is this for well making money now
and this is paying you back for
headshots electric bills and make money
a common collocation that means to earn
money example he makes a lot of money in
the auto parts business we have a lot of
different ways to talk about making
money for example we say someone's
killing it when they're making a lot of
money however if you are earning little
we say you are barely getting by or
you're struggling to make ends meet
when you reach the end of the month and
have very
money left payback to return an amount
of money that someone lent to you can I
borrow five bucks from you I'll pay you
back tomorrow headshot a picture of a
person's face for professional or formal
use so many slices of pizza I can't even
count that I can that I can't even count
now I can get my pony I can get my pony
Chandler is joking that with all this
unexpected money he can buy something
ridiculous like a pony the humor is that
many little girls want their own pony
and also that this is obviously
something that no one in New York City
would buy this is a little extra
something for you know always being
there for me a little something we
sometimes use these words together to
mean a present or gift example I got a
little something for you to be there for
someone this means that you make
yourself available to support someone
when they have a problem example she was
really there for me when my grandma died
wow I don't know what to say I don't
know what to say we see this expression
used in two ways here which depend
completely on the tone of voice first it
is used to as a thank you a similar to
words can't express my gratitude
but then humorously the meaning changes
when Chandler actually sees what the
gift is in this case he doesn't know
what to say because he is shocked
example I didn't know what to say when
my boss said he wanted me to work on
Christmas
now listen to the tone when Chandler
says it in surprise
Wow I don't know what to say finally
Joey says what do you say which is a way
to solicit a response from someone
similar to what do you think example
what if we go fishing this weekend just
the two of us what do you say it's a
bracelet to my best bud and grave to cut
into a hard material so is to write
something
Chandler's bracelet has to my best bud
and graved on it bud short for buddy
which is another word for friend put it
on put something on to start wearing a
specific piece of clothing example put
your socks on no no I think something
that's nice should be saved for a
special occasion a special occasion a
day that has significance for example a
birthday or anniversary or in
celebration of an accomplishment example
is a special occasion you just got
promoted let's break out the good
champagne oh no no that's the beauty
part
the beauty of something used to mention
what makes something convenient
appealing practical etc example the
beauty of working from home is that you
don't need to spend hundreds of dollars
a month on commuting go with something
if a piece of clothing goes with another
it means they match or look good
together especially because their colors
combine example do you think these shoes
go with this dress good to go we say
this when someone is completely ready to
do something especially because they
have everything they need here Joey's
saying that when Chandler wears the
bracelet he doesn't need anything else
to make him look good example described
with someone you just need to have a
working microphone cam and you're good
to go
[Music]
hi so I am you are so doing something
this expression means that something is
in someone's best interest to do for
example you are so coming to Paris with
me that first Spring Break we will have
a great time you are so going to pass
the test you've studied all week
Chandler's response I so M is funny
because he means it literally he's in
disbelief that he is physically wearing
this ugly gold bracelet this will do for
your sex life probably slow it down at
first but once I get used to the extra
weight I'll be back on track B or get
back on track to start doing something
well again example last year was hard
for us but things are back on track now
the joke in Chandler's mentioning the
weight of the bracelet is that his love
life is in his hand that is masturbation
sparkly if something is sparkly it
shines in flashes like the sparkly coat
in the picture flashy looking too bright
and expensive especially to get
attention not for a good fella
Ross is implying that a good fella which
is a violent criminal involved in
organized crime like the Robert De Niro
movie and stereotypically of Italian
ethnicity might wear a flashy piece of
jewelry like this sharp nice attractive
and with style example look at you in
that sharp tuxedo that must have cost
you quite a few doubloons that must have
cost you quite a few doubloons doubloons
old Spanish gold coins stereotypically
used by pirates
Monica is making the joke that the
bracelet looks like some sort of pirate
treasure right get something right
to do something well dude 11 o'clock
totally hot babe checking you out
that's really good think I'm ready for
my penis 11 o'clock an imaginary way of
positioning an object or person in space
based on the idea that the observer is
located in the center of an imaginary
clock something at 12 o'clock is
directly in front of him or her babe
informal way to refer to a woman who you
find very attractive click at the top
for an article all about different ways
to speak about beauty check someone out
to look at someone with sexual desire
example he was checking out my friend
I'm ready for my penis now in this part
of the scene Phoebe is obviously doing
something that a man would usually do
pointing out a hot woman to his friend
in her opinion she does such a good job
that she could actually be a man I know
what you're thinking I know what you
think I know what you're thinking Dave
Thomas founder of Wendy's Wendy's a fast
food chain in the USA generally thought
to be of better quality than McDonald's
or Burger King the founder Dave Thomas
used to be in Wendy's commercials in the
1990s Chandler is flirting with her by
making the joke here that she must be
staring at him because she thinks he is
a famous person even though he looks
nothing like Dave Thomas you know he
could have got me a VCR he could have
got me a set of golf clubs but no he has
to get me the woman repeller VCR and
golf clubs a VCR is a video cassette
recorder which used to be used to watch
tapes this shows the age of friends a
golf club is the stick with which a
golfer hits the golf ball repeller or
repellent something that causes a
version or dislike the funny concept of
a woman repeller much like a mosquito
repellent is designed to keep women away
eyesore from the Liberace House of crap
I saw a sword is an infection so an
eyesore is an infection on the eye but
figuratively an eyesore is something
that is unattractive and hard to look at
example many Parisians believe the
Eiffel Tower is actually a bit of an
eyesore
Liberace House of crap Liberace was an
American pianist and singer famous for
dressing and flashy clothes and jewelry
his house of crap might be a place for
his rejects the things that not even
Liberace would want to wear all right
can you give me an example of something
that you think is an eyesore down in the
comments below we will be correcting
many of your examples so I look forward
to seeing what you say also if you want
to learn and master so much more of the
vocabulary expressions pronunciation
that you are learning in this lesson
don't forget your present the PDF power
lesson you can download that right now
and we will even send you by email a
hilarious three-part mini course with
the funniest ever seen from friends all
right
go and do that now and then we'll get
back into today's lesson oh yeah easy
for you to say you don't the walk around
sporting some reject from the mr. t
collection easy for you to say used to
say that it's easy to say something when
you're not the one who has to make a
sacrifice example she says I should
travel more but that's easy for her to
say because she doesn't have kids to
sport as a verb this word is used in an
informal way meaning to where example I
think I saw you supporting a Red Sox cap
this morning some reject from the mr. t
collection mr. t was a character in the
TV series the a-team the war a lot of
cold jewelry
so what Chandler's saying is that he got
a reject that is an object that was not
accepted because it wasn't good enough
for mr. T's collection of gold and
jewelry I pity the fool
I pity the fool this was mr. T's
catchphrase that is a phrase a character
or famous person often says and is
famous for he would say that any time he
would get upset at someone but what he's
actually saying is I'm sorry for the guy
who is about to get beat up by me no I
don't hate that boy but I pity the fool
and I would destroy any man who tries to
T what I got hey man we were just doing
some impressions over here
do your myself myself that's actually
good do an impression to imitate how a
person talks moves or behaves Marcel
Marceau a famous mime that is a silent
performer
Chandler says that Joey's impression was
pretty good because he walked out
angrily without saying anything well
doesn't the fact that I wore the
bracelet even though I hated it say
something about our friendship and how
much it means to me mean a lot to
someone saying that something means a
lot to you equals to saying that it's
very important or has a lot of value for
you example thanks for all the help it
means a lot to me well what about the
fact that you insulted the bracelet and
you made fun of me make fun of someone
too rudely laugh at someone's expense
example my brother always made fun of me
when we were young but now we're really
close ok well that's the part where I'm
a wank a wank a jerk get out of the
bitter barn and play in the hay bitter
is an adjective used to describe
feelings of anger and unhappiness bye
get out of the bitter barn Phoebe is
essentially saying Chandler's stop
complaining and play in the hay which is
a metaphorical way of saying he should
cheer up or feel happier this is not a
common expression forget about the fact
I just dropped $400 to replace a
bracelet that I hated to begin with
bring on the hay drop on something to
spend a large amount of money at one
time example I can't believe you dropped
$200 in that toy for his kid bring on
something it means you are completely
ready and angrily awaiting something
Chandler obviously means this our cast
eclis example I'm tired of the cold
weather
bring on the summer how come you have to
well this one's for you get out said to
indicate disbelief at a surprising truth
also commonly said as get outta here
example personname I just asked Mary out
and she said yes person B get out really
hey I got something for you
what's this 812 bucks well I don't know
what big Leon told you but it's an even
thousand if you want me for the whole
night what is this for
Oh making money now and this is paying
you back for headshots electric bills
and so many slices of pizza I can't even
count I Love You Man well thanks man now
I can get my pony this is a little extra
something for uh you know always being
there for me wow I don't know what to
say wow I don't know what to say
it's a bracelet it's great - check it
out - my best bud thanks best bud put it
on oh no no no I think something this
nice should be saved for a special
occasion
oh no no that's the beauty part it goes
with everything you're good to go
you are so wearing that bracelet hi so I
am you have any idea what this will do
for your sex life well I'm probably
slowed it down at first but once I get
used to the extra weight I'll be back on
track
you know Nan's got a point
yeah it's a little flashy no no no it's
not flashy not for a good fella sure
that must have cost you quite a few
doubloons okay give me a second I want
to get this just right dude
eleven o'clock totally hot babe checking
you out that's really good think I'm
ready for my penis
[Applause]
I know what you're thinking Dave Thomas
founder of Wendy's I'm Gayle jelly I
really have to be somewhere but it was
nice meeting you
buzzes excellent you know he could have
got me a VCR he could have got me a set
of golf clubs but no yes to get me the
woman repeller the eyesore from the
Liberace House of crap oh yeah easy for
you to say you don't the walk around
sporting some reject from the mr. t
collection I pity the fool who puts on
my food hey man we were just doing some
impressions over here
do your myself myself that's actually
good if you hated the bracelet so much
channeling you should have just said so
well isn't the fact that I wore the
bracelet even though I hated it say
something about our friendship and how
much it means to me well what about the
fact that you insulted the bracelet and
you made fun of me okay well that's the
part where I'm a wank some people
wouldn't focus on that come on man I
said I was sorry like a hundred times I
promise I will never take it off my
wrist
if you want to stay in there and be mad
you know you just you stay in there I
can't believe did you stop already get
out of the bitter barn and play in the
hay oh you're right I should play in the
hay forget about the fact I just dropped
$400 to replace a bracelet that I hated
to begin with bring on the hay I've got
something that's gonna make you happy
yes a gun your phone oh no you have to
what am I gonna do huh hey hey how come
you have to well this one's for you no I
can't no no listen I I know how much
this means to you and I also know that
this is about more than just jewelry
it's about you and me and the fact that
we're best buds
oh is this friendship I think so check
it out with recent buddies
that's what they'll call us all right
wait to make it all the way to the end
of the lesson you are kicking ass with
your English which is exactly what we
hope that we are helping you do with
this English channel so be sure to
subscribe and remember to get your PDF
power lesson if I did not say it enough
times you can do that by clicking right
over here subscribe by clicking right up
here and I have another lesson I think
you'll enjoy just click right here
alright now go out there and continue to
kick ass with your English oh yeah